hey this is presh talwalkar reminding
you to mind your decisions
start with the square whose side length
is 10.
draw an inscribed circle and then draw
two quarter circles
solve for the area shaded in blue using
only primary school maths
that means trigonometry is allowed but
calculus is not allowed
this was asked in china to 11 year olds
pause the video if you'd like to give it
a try and when you're ready keep
watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
we'll get started with some useful
geometry formulas
the area of a circular sector is one
half times r squared multiplied by the
central angle theta
if we have a triangle with two sides a
and b and an angle c in between them
its area is one half a b multiplied by
the sine of angle c
now if the triangle has the same
dimensions as the circular sector
we then get the formula one half r
squared sine of theta
if we then subtract this triangle from
the circular sector we get the area of a
circular segment
and that will become one half r squared
multiplied by the quantity theta minus
sine of theta
next if we have a triangle with sides a
b and c we can solve for the angle c
opposite side c using alkashi's law of
cosines
the angle c will be the following it'll
be the inverse cosine of a squared plus
b squared minus c squared all over 2ab
so now let's solve the problem
we'll draw a diagonal of the square
since the square has a side length of 10
its diagonal will be 10 times the square
root of 2.
this means half of the diagonal will be
5 times the square root of 2.
next we'll draw a radii of the inscribed
circle since the inscribed circle has a
diameter of 10 its radius will be 5.
now we'll draw radii of this quarter
circle
it'll have a length of 10 because it's
exactly the same length as the side of
the square
finally we'll draw this chord
let's now focus on one of the triangles
in this diagram
we know all three sides of the triangle
so let's solve for this angle a
we'll use alkashi's law of cosines we'll
substitute in the values we have for
this triangle and then solve for the
angle a
we'll put that to the side and now we'll
solve for this angle b
we'll again use el kashi's law of
cosines we'll substitute in the values
for this triangle
and then we'll solve for the value of
angle b
now notice that by symmetry this is also
angle b
so this will be c which is equal to two
pi minus two b
we'll calculate the angle c
again by symmetry this is angle a so we
can solve for the value of two a
we'll now calculate the area of this
circular sector
we'll then subtract the area of this
triangle
and we'll get the area of this circular
segment
we'll simplify this a little bit and
we'll put it to the side
we'll now calculate the area of this
circular sector and then subtract the
area of this following triangle
and then we'll get the area of this
circular segment in red
we get this formula and then we'll
simplify it
and now we want to take the area of this
red shape from the area of this purple
shape
so that'll be pretty much our answer
we'll subtract the red shape from the
purple shape
but just for fun let's simplify this a
little bit
we have the sine of c so we'll
substitute in the value for c
we'll use some trigonometric identities
and then we'll use the double angle
identity
sine of 2 times an angle will be 2 times
the cosine of the angle multiplied by
the sine of the angle
the cosine of the inverse cosine of a
quantity will simplify
then we have the sine of the inverse
cosine of a quantity
we can draw a right triangle
this is the value of the cosine in this
triangle so we can solve for the sine of
the angle
and we substitute that in
so we simplify this and we figure out
what sine of c is equal to
we'll substitute that and then we'll do
the same sort of thing for sine of 2
times a
we'll use some trigonometric identities
then we'll simplify
and then we'll draw a triangle and we'll
again calculate the sine of this
triangle
this allows us to simplify even further
and we get what sine of 2a is equal to
now when we take the red shape from the
purple shape we end up with the blue
shape
but we need the value of two of these
blue shapes so we'll multiply everything
by two
next we can substitute in our values of
c and a
and then we'll simplify and we end up
with this exact form of the answer and
this is approximately
29.276 and don't forget the square
centimeters
and that's our answer
now at this point we've done a lot of
work so it'll always be good to check
your answer and we're going to check it
using calculus
so we have our shape and we'll put a
coordinate system in place
we'll then put this point as 10 comma 0.
we'll then calculate the equation of
this arc
then we have the equation of this lower
part of this circle and then the
equation of this upper part of the
circle
we can then calculate the intersection
of the lower part of the circle with
this quarter circle
and then we calculate the intersection
of this upper circle with the quarter
circle
we now have three functions and we can
calculate the area as follows
so the first part of the shape will be
the integral that's going from x1 to x2
of f of 1 minus f of 2.
the remaining will be the integral that
goes from x2 to 10 of f of 3 minus f of
2.
now with these integrals we can
numerically calculate and get that the
answer of one of these blue segments
will be
approximately 14.638
we want the area of two of them so we
multiply by two and again we get 29.276
so it's a pretty neat problem and i
really like that you can approach it
both using trigonometry and using
calculus
thanks for watching and for making mind
your decisions one of the best channels
on youtube thanks for watching and
thanks for your support
[Music]
[Music]
you